madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce samedi 30 octobre
les britanniques espèrent une levée
rapide de l'embargo français sur leur
viande de boeuf
en attendant les autorités affichent un
triomphe modeste
je n'ai juste pas achève ce soir son
voyage en guadeloupe un voyage contrarié
par l' affaire de la mnef sur laquelle
le premier ministre ne s'est pas
prononcé
le tunnel du mont-blanc symboliquement
muré cet après midi par les habitants
dans la vallée de chamonix qui
manifestent contre la réouverture prévue
à l'automne 2000 et puis solidarité
enfants sida à 20h50 vous pourrez suivre
la soirée exceptionnelle des chanteurs
français en faveur de l'association sol
en si michel jonasz nous en parlera dans
ce journal
dans quelques instants c'est
incontestablement une victoire pour les
britanniques dans la bataille qui les
opposait à la france sur la vache folle
londres attend maintenant ils devaient
rapide de l'embargo français sur la
viande britannique et le gouvernement de
tony blair entend bien maintenir la
pression à londres benoît duquesne a pu
mesurer la satisfaction des agriculteurs
et des consommateurs
ken garrett a appris la nouvelle hier
soir dans sa ferme de labeur avec son
fils il a réussi à se maintenir à flot
pendant toutes ces années de crise sans
doute parce qu'il a un bon troupeau de
250 vaches et parce qu'il a eu la chance
de ne pas être touchée directement par
la maladie mais quelle gare est comme
les autres fermiers anglais a vu ses
revenus diminuer de 70% ces deux
dernières années et il n'ose imaginer ce
qu'aurait été les conséquences d'un
échec à bruxelles il ya beaucoup service
et qu'ils sont désespérés ils perdent
tout continuer les banques ne les
soutiennent
l'huile sont à découvert et je crois
qu'il y aurait eu encore beaucoup de
suisses
car c'est toute l'agriculture
britannique qui est exemple parce que
les cours se sont effondrés parce que
les coûts eux mêmes ont progressé à
cause des nouvelles réglementations
imposées par bruxelles
on ne compte plus les fermiers en
faillite li même ceux qui se suicident
59 l'an dernier alors quand ils ont
appris la nouvelle hier soir les gars
est père et fils préféré rester prudent
c'est la deuxième fois que les
scientifiques européens nous disent que
notre boeuf et sain peut être que
maintenant les français le laisseront
passer car pour l'instant les éleveurs
anglais en sont réduits à promouvoir eux
mêmes leurs produits auprès des
consommateurs anglais et à s'en remettre
à leurs gouvernements pour qu'ils
obtiennent rapidement une levée de
l'embargo
le gouvernement français c'est que nous
souhaitons une réponse rapide et positif
de savoir que nous sommes en contact
avec la commission pour faire un
pressing en ce sens les anglais ont donc
encore deux batailles à livrer l'une
contre le gouvernement français dont il
se méfie en se disant qu'après un tel
revers il vous reste encore négocier
pour trouver une porte de sortie et
sauver la face
et puis l'autre bataille va consister
pour eux à reconquérir les marchés
perdus à regagner la confiance des
consommateurs européens
et cette bataille là s'annonce beaucoup
plus longue et plus difficile alors
évidemment cette décision en france
provoquent un certain embarras
le ministre de l'agriculture doit fixer
les modalités de levée de cet embargo
est déjà producteur et consommateur
insiste sur les nécessaires étiquetage
indiquant la provenance des viandes
cyrille devaud du boeuf britannique dans
les supermarchés français trop risqué
selon les associations de consommateurs
pour elle les cas de vache folle sont
encore trop nombreux chez nos voisins
anglais je savoir qu'ils vont terminer
l'année avec au moins deux mille bêtes
contaminées
c'est quand même énorme encore même
s'ils font des efforts je dirais que
c'est plutôt une décision politique et
diplomatique qui va être prise et qui
risque de ne pas prendre suffisamment en
compte les intérêts de santé publique
rôti ou bifteck en france trois quarts
du boeuf est vendu en boucherie le reste
est incorporé dans les plats cuisinés et
les steaks hachés impossible dans ce cas
de connaître l'origine de la viande
une situation inacceptable pour les
professionnels de la filière bovine
française
si un aliment contient du veuf anglais
il faut que tout le monde le sache
nous demandons simplement que toutes les
viandes souhaite identifier avec
l'origine pour que le consommateur
achète en connaissance de cause cela
nécessite effectivement une traçabilité
parfaite et une information sur la
viande anglaise tant dans les points de
vente qu'en collectivité
désavoué par le comité scientifique
européen la france est priée de lever
l'embargo au plus vite une décision qui
embarrasse le premier ministre interrogé
hier en guadeloupe
nous allons rentrer à paris dimanche
matin et nous examinerons ça il n'y a
pas de décision qui devrait être au delà
de ce qui a été annoncé par le comité
directeur scientifique mais qui devrait
être prise avant le début de la semaine
dont nous avons le temps de regarder
chaque chantier
le gouvernement joue la montre il
aimerait obtenir l'étiquetage
systématique du boeuf anglais à porter
histoire de sortir honorablement de la
crise tout en rassurant les
consommateurs français
un compromis que paris et londres
négocieront mardi prochain à bruxelles
après le feu vert donné hier au juge
pour enquêter sur les liens entre
dominique strauss kahn et la mnef c'est
la question de la mise en examen du
ministre qui se pose maintenant selon le
code de procédure pénale le juge peut
choisir entre la mise en examen ou une
audition en tant que témoin mais qui
nécessite en l'occurrence une
autorisation formelle du conseil des
ministres les explications d'olivier
caroff éviter la mise en examen depuis
hier les avocats de dominique strauss
kahn planchent sur ce scénario
pris dans la tourmente de l'affairé nef
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances sera nécessairement entendue
par les juges d'instruction mais un
alinéa du code de procédure pénale
pourrait lui épargner cette mise en
examen quelques lignes qui prévoit qu'il
peut être interrogé en tant que témoin
assisté de ses défenseurs il faut
d'abord les juges soient d'accord
il faut ensuite un débat en conseil des
ministres pour autoriser dominique
strauss kahn a témoigné le premier
ministre serait alors obligée d'aborder
la sphère nef devant le président de la
république pour l'instant lionel jospin
ne fait aucun commentaire sur la mise en
cause de l'un de ses principaux
ministres
le dossier mnef il n'en a parlé
publiquement qu'une fois c'était il ya
un an
le concerner des responsables
socialistes dont certains dit on vous
serez proche que les votre cinquième
votre sentiment est ce que ça vous
inquiète
mais nous verrons bien si des
responsables socialistes ou non sont
concernés par la sphère de la même un
certain nombre de faits ont été transmis
au parquet donc des procédures
judiciaires ont auront lieu peut-être et
on verra qui se rend qui sera en cause
en cette circonstance et chacun assume
individuellement sa propre
responsabilité
une formule que lionel jospin va devoir
clarifier dominique strauss kahn rentre
très tôt demain matin du vietnam lionel
jospin lui revient de martinique
quelques heures plus tard les deux
hommes auront à aborder la question à
très brève échéance
le premier ministre pour leur observent
le plus grand mutisme sur cette affaire
et poursuit son voyage en guadeloupe où
il s'est rendu cet après midi dans un
quartier défavorisé de pointe à pitre
il y a été accueillie avec une ferveur
qui adulent rasséréné car cette affaire
est tout de même venu perturber son
voyage sur place roland sicard et ja
gregor
pour se changer les idées c'est bien
connu rien ne vaut un bon voyage aux
antilles et quelques bonnes surprises
alors pour lionel jospin malgré la nef
malgré la vache folle
malgré le ciel qui s'assombrit à paris
pas question de changer une ligne du
propre manade quet sites résidentiels
dans les rues de pointe à pitre est un
objectif pour le premier ministre contre
attaqué en affichant sa bonne humeur
si vous regardez les choses vous voyez
ce premier portrait vraisemblablement
tirées en métropole je suis un peu pâlot
alors je me disais que si j'étais resté
peut-être aurais-je pu prendre une belle
couleur brune timoré sied au tas et
lorsqu un peu plus loin des manifestants
viennent troubler la fête et réclame la
libération d'un syndicaliste
indépendantiste lors ce qu'ils accusent
en député guadeloupéen d'être au service
des blancs lionel jospin autres un autre
aspect de sa contre attaque
la fermeté c'est entendu tout à l'heure
parmi les slogans que vous créiez negra
blanc il n'y a pas de [ __ ] blancs
guadeloupe
il n'y a pas de blanc un [ __ ] il
helvétique et glace des indiens et il
doit vivre tous ensemble dans la
république est gros comme citoyen lionel
jospin qui après ce déplacement aux
antilles va maintenant rentrer à paris
où l'attend un dossier particulièrement
délicat celui de la mise en cause de
dominique strauss-kahn dans la sphère de
la nef le premier ministre va devoir
trancher très vite avec une question
peut-il conserver au gouvernement un
ministre qui depuis deux ans est une des
pièces essentielles de son dispositif
politique elle ne l'est pas avait prévu
de consacrer essentiellement son voyage
à la situation économique des antilles
où les statistiques en termes d'emploi
sont catastrophiques 30 % de chômeurs
12% de la population allocataires du rmi
une assertion qui a bien du mal à être
effectués sur place comme le montre ce
reportage de pascal golomer et emmanuel
beck le cyclone n'est pas passé bien
loin l'alertent sur la guadeloupe vient
tout juste d'être levé ce matin selon
rudy et jean-marie sont venus travailler
chez leurs patrons charpentier de marine
à port louis d'habitude ils sont huit à
fabriquer ces barques traditionnelles
tous allocataires du rmi
lagence d'inception leur a proposé un
contrat à mi temps payé au smic pour six
mois une aubaine pour l'artisan à qui
cela ne coûte rien si ce n'est le temps
de formation il dit pourtant être l'un
des rares à faire confiance à ses jeunes
les garçons des années
on ne peut pas travailler tellement pas
beaucoup et veut seulement gagner de
l'argent sans travailler maintenant la
réputation qu'ont les gens qui sont au
rmi aujourd'hui le rmi faute de mieux
c'est ce que répondre rudy et jean-marie
tout en reconnaissant accepter des
petits boulots non déclaré comme
beaucoup parmi les 58 la locataire de la
guanine il faut bien arrondir les femmes
mais a passé vous avez des enfants
au fait un tibia bas côté
bon si vous avez droit et l'état belge
ne sait pas tout est tiré sain quand
même assez la cnep a déclaré il faut
vivre il faut construire autour et on
les mois séparent est par contre
difficile pour l'administration
d'évaluer le poids de cette économie
souterraine
le nombre d'emplois dissimulé difficile
aussi pour l' agence d'insertion de
proposer à tous les rmistes des
solutions sérieuses d'autant que les
employeurs rechignent à embaucher une
populations exclues du marché du travail
depuis plusieurs années notre problème
c'est en quelque sorte d'augmenter la
proportion des rmistes qui accèdent aux
emplois tels qu'ils existent et puis en
même temps de participer à toutes les
initiatives qui sont prises pour créer
des emplois nouveaux
qu'est ce que nous appelons le
développement local les initiatives en
matière de développement local création
d'activités etc
l'an dernier huit mille coadout p1 sont
entrés dans le dispositif du rmi un
record si aucun moyen supplémentaire ne
lui est consacré la mission d'insertion
tiens donc du pari impossible sarron
coquette cité de corrèze dont bernadette
chirac est adjointe au maire accueillera
le futur musée du septennat
cet après midi le président de la
république et ce sont les groupes se
sont rendus sur place pour visiter le
chantier de mise et qui abritera donc il
est présent remis au couple présidentiel
pendant le septennat et vous le voyez
sur cette image
le président de la république a reçu la
clé du futur musée
il y à quelques heures dans le parc du
château de versailles un avion de
tourisme s'est écrasé causant la mort de
trois personnes
l'accident s'est produit à proximité du
grand canal dans une prairie
les trois occupants de l'appareil ont
été tuées sur le coup selon les pompiers
il s'agit de deux hommes et d'une femme
dont l'identité n'ont pas été
communiqués
l'avion venait de décoller de
l'aérodrome tout proche de saint cyr
l'école
le tunnel du mont-blanc symboliquement
muré cet après midi par les habitants de
la vallée de chamonix
fermé depuis l' incendie qui avait fait
39 morts en mars dernier le tunnel
pourrait rouvrir à l'automne 2000 une
soixantaine d'associations françaises
italiennes et suisses dénoncent ce
projet reportage benoît gadret et gilles
perret un mur symbolique pour empêcher
le passage des camions
un mur érigé à 100 mètres de l'entrée du
tunnel du mont blanc
car la plateforme d'accès protégée par
un grillage est désormais inaccessible
cela fait sept mois que la catastrophe a
eu lieu c'est moins que les chamoniards
vie sans camion mais dans un an le
tunnel doit ré ouvrir et la balle et ne
veut plus être asphyxie vous rendez
compte jusque 6 800 mille camions par an
deux mille cinq cents camions jour avec
des pointes à 5000 et en nous annonce
comme ça pour l'europe dans disons 5005
mis au jour des pointes à déminer 7 le
dire un camion toutes les dix secondes
la pétition lancée par l'association de
sauvegarde a recueilli cent mille
signatures par solidarité la plupart des
commerçants ont fermé boutique cet après
midi car l'économie locale à quelques
exceptions près se porte plutôt bien son
camion la veille chamonix comme toutes
les vallées alpines 1 comme les vallées
des pyrénées les cols des pyrénées n'ont
absolument pas besoin des poids lourds
pour vivre au contraire c'est une
nuisance importante d'une nuisance
environnement une nuisance accidentelle
non absolument pas besoin des poids
lourds pour vivre au contraire les 1500
chamoniard rassemblés cet après-midi ont
reçu le soutien d'une soixantaine
d'associations européennes en
particulier des écologistes du val
d'aoste eux aussi mobilisés et nous
avons vaincu à 1 3 mois vingt mille
signatures qui fait beaucoup pour une
région qui est très peu peuplée
les mois à venir risquent d'être agités
dans la vallée entre l'état actionnaire
majoritaire de la société du tunnel et
les habitants de chamonix le bras de fer
ne fait que commencer
en corse alors que le délai de
démolition des paillotes s'achève demain
soir certains de ses restaurants de
plage pour on continue en toute légalité
à exercer leur activité
cette différence de traitement
s'explique par les subtilités des règles
d'urbanisme et les contours du domaine
public maritime enquête sur place agnès
vahramian et jean-pierre pasteur
c'est là que chanter tino rossi
marinella un restaurant célèbre de la
baie d'ajaccio
bâti sur une plage publique le patron
est avec un responsable de la direction
départementale de l'équipement par nina
est une paillote construites sur le
domaine public maritime
et pourtant en règle de trois titulaires
d'une autorisation payer une redevance
est respectée les surfaces qui sont
autorisés sur france j'essaie son propre
carré mais s'adapte 49 abaissement et et
yan carabeau main donc
c'est paillotes en face ne sont pas
toutes au fusil mais pour les déloger
la dde doit avec elle je suis le domaine
public maritime soit en partie sur le
guen privé et en partie sur la plage
alors qu'est ce que ça vous pose comme
problème on se pose un problème de
délimitation du domaine public parce
qu'on a tant il est difficile de
délimiter la plage une fois les
établissements se faire contrôler le
domaine public maritime c'est la limite
du sable et de la montée des eaux par
tempête ce dp m
personne ne peut se l'approprier îles
féroe de la paillote chez francis a
toujours contesté occuper ce domaine
public
le tribunal lui a donné tort il est sur
le dpm alors que quelques mètres
derrière chez lui
cette petite paillote ne l'est pas et ne
sera pas détruite rester près de la
plage pour ses papiers qui démonte
aujourd'hui c'est un vrai casse tête
j'attends le permis de construire ici
dans le parking un peu plus plus en
amont dans le domaine privé
voilà ce que j'attends mais ces zones
protégées là bas non là c'est la bande
des 100 mètres il portait juste l'autre
côté de la route
je veux dire il faut le protéger mais
aussi peut-être à moins de 100 mètres de
l'eau la loi littoral s'applique c'est
inconstructibles là c'est une zone
protégée impossible de bâtir autorisé ou
pas de nouvelles paillotes en corse
aujourd'hui c'est pour l'état et les
collectivités locales ont signé le
tourisme de masse et la préservation de
l'environnement
l'usagé de la cocaïne qui reste
relativement limitée en europe pourrait
dangereusement se développer comme ce
fut le cas aux états unis dans les
années 80 c'est ce que redoutent les
spécialistes américains l'un d'entre eux
conseiller de bill clinton matière de
drogues effectue depuis hier une tournée
européenne pour sensibiliser les
pouvoirs publics à ce qu'il appelle les
nouveaux débouchés de la cocaïne
pascal douce est bon et olivier robert
l'ont rencontré limousine gardes du
corps les déplacements de barry
mccaffrey sont à l'image du surnom que
la presse américaine lui a donné le tsar
de la drogue
rien que ça ce conseiller de bill
clinton règne sur un budget de 110
milliards de francs par an une fois et
demi celui de la justice en france
en une décennie il a fait chuter de 70%
la consommation de cocaïne aux états
il ya quinze jours encore 30 trafiquants
étaient arrêtés en colombie par la
police locale
sur indication américaine fort de ses
succès barry mccaffrey est venu adresser
un avertissement à l'europe la drogue
cherchent de nouveaux marchés est comme
la cocaïne ne peut être vendu dans le
tiers monde
il ne reste que l'europe aux trafiquants
qui trouve là un marché potentiel deux
fois supérieur à celui des etats unis
aujourd'hui le marché américain est en
chute libre
mais dans les années 80 nous avions
tardé à prendre conscience du problème
l'europe doit absolument être alertés
pour ne pas faire la même erreur
effectivement les saisies de cocaïne en
europe n'ont cessé de croître en dix ans
l'espagne et les pays bas sont les
premiers concernés en 98
la france était au cinquième rang elle
dépassera certainement les prévisions à
la fin de cette année puisque la police
a saisi en février 12 100 kg d'un coup
dissimulé entre autres dans du matériel
forain policiers responsables
associatifs
tous reconnaissent qu'en france la
cocaïne n'a pas toujours été traités à
l'égal des autres stupéfiants drogue de
riches moins dangereuse que l'héroïne ou
disait ton le message de barry mccaffrey
fait aujourd'hui radicalement évoluer
son discours une atrocité sans
équivalent cent quarante enfants
assassinés en colombie par un fou
psychopathe de 42 ans et l'a reconnu ses
crimes perpétrés pendant sept ans la
police se livrent maintenant à une
douloureuse exhumation des corps des
petites victimes massacrées déjà 117
cadavres ont été retrouvés commentaires
isabelle stays sur des images difficile
la tâche de ces enquêteurs que l'on bien
est à la mesure de l'horreur du crime
dans ces sacs en plastique
il collecte les ossements des victimes
114 squelettes d'enfants et
d'adolescents ainsi découvert dans les
faubourgs d'une soixantaine de villes à
travers toute la colombie des garçons
entre 8 et 16 ans violée torturée et
décapité par cet homme que l'on présente
désormais comme le plus fou des
criminels son entourage d'ailleurs le
surnomme dingo luis alfredo gare à
vitteaux 42 ans a avoué au total le
meurtre de 140 enfants pour la plupart
des gosses de rue ou de familles pauvres
qu'il abordait en se faisant passer pour
un mendiant ou un prêtre arrêté en avril
dernier après une tentative de viol gare
à vitteaux décrit comme un malade mental
aura ainsi massacrés pendant sept ans
faisant de lui le pire tueur en série de
l'histoire criminelle
et puis les derniers soldats indonésiens
ont quitté le territoire du timor
oriental
aujourd'hui mettant ainsi un terme à 24
ans de présence
après des semaines de terreur et de
massacres le timor oriental pourrait
enfin devoir devrait enfin pouvoir vivre
son indépendance l'australie s'est
qualifiée pour la demi finale de la
coupe du monde de rugby en battant
l'afrique du sud tenant du titre 27 à 21
après prolongation au cours de ce match
n'est les springboks ce n'est les
wallabies n'ont marqué d'essai nathanaël
de rincquesen voilà on australien
mouillé mais heureux après cinq minutes
de jeu les wallabies sont finalement
venus à bout des springboks
sud-africains au terme d'un match marqué
par les pénalités pendant toute la durée
de la rencontre
matthew burke l'australien en jaune et
johnny de beer
le sud africain en verre se rendent coup
pour coup
l'arbitré siffle les buteurs marque
à ce petit jeu les australiens semblent
devoir se qualifier mais alors que le
temps réglementaire est terminé depuis
cinq minutes
l'afrique du sud obtient une dernière
pénalité est l'occasion d'égaliser
jannie de beer ne tremble pas 18 partout
c'est la prolongation
dans cette avalanche de pénalités dans
ce match sans essai l'issue est
finalement trouvé sur un drop de 42
mètres réussie par l'australien steve la
can
son large sourire en dit long sur sa
performance
et comme pour enlever tout regret au sud
africain qui perdent leurs titres nature
burke inscrit la 14e et dernière
pénalité de la rencontre
score final 27 21 l'australie se
qualifie pour la finale sans marquer le
moindre essai et demain autre demi
finale la france rencontre les all
blacks à twickenham
un match qui s'annonce très difficile
aux mots clés du dispositif français
l'entraîneur jean-claude skréla ancien
international du quinze de france
christophe duchiron et frédéric bazille
nous explique dans quel état d'esprit le
patron de l'équipe de france aborde
cette demi finale quatre ans à la tête
de l'équipe de france à s'agiter les
sens sur un ciel de tribu en monsieur
perfectionniste et passionné de quelques
défaites monumentales on succès
retentissant jean-claude skréla
entraîneur des bleus pour portes d'une
finale en coupe du monde
mais devant la porte il y un gros chat
noir c'est sûr qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup
de charges y en a peut-être une sur dix
urbaine sur 30 je suis pas rêver celle
là il faut il faut la saisir les blacks
ça gagne souvent je dirais presque
toujours et sa paire de tyson tant comme
joueur il aurait voulu être black temps
qu'il aime ce rugby total du bout du
monde comme entraîneur de l'équipe de
france en trois rencontres à venir dans
mon loire il a connu un destin pour le
moins contrasté novembre 95 à toulouse
pour son troisième match à la tête des
bleus les bleus s'imposent 22 à 15 à ce
jour c'est la dernière victoire
française face aux blacks
une semaine plus tard à paris revanche
néo-zélandaise des faits tricolore 37 à
cette fois là on n'arrêtait pas de jonah
lomu
juin 99 énorme défaite française 54 à 7
après la demi finale de dimanche
prochain que fera jean-claude skréla
certains ont déjà évoqué sa succession
avant qu'il n'était évoqué son départ
je sais même pas moi ce que je vais
faire après la coupe du monde ne dorment
que qu'est ce que je vais faire le
lendemain que je fais je le sais rien
j'ai jamais calculé ça
il n'y a qu'une chose qui est sûre c'est
que je pense avoir beaucoup plus
serviles ruby que m servi du rugby il ne
fait pas de doute que jean-claude skréla
soit un honnête homme
et en cette période de coupe du monde il
n'est pas sans rappeler parfois aimé
jacquet entraîneur d'une équipe qui
gagnait sont toujours couverts et qui un
jour bâti le brésil et si les rugbymen
français battait la nouvelle zélande
évidemment le rêve
vous connaissez sûrement sa silhouette
rondouillette et ses disputes
récurrentes avec son irascible voisins
achille talon créée en 1963 était le
héros le plus connu de michel régnier
dit craig hauteur de 250 albums il est
mort brutalement hier soir à son
domicile de neuilly daniel wolfromm au
dernier festival d'angoulême en janvier
la grande vedette
c'était ce vieux monsieur débonnaire au
milieu des enfants la consécration pour
greg et son personnage achille talon
tour à tour bonhomme est agressif
perpétuellement aux prises avec les
tracas du quotidien grec avait été un
des scénaristes d'hergé avant de diriger
la rédaction deux pilotes entrés dans la
bd à l'âge de 16 ans il avait conservé
son âme de gamin
il faut être un adulte pour avoir l'idée
de vendre ses rêves d'enfant quand j'y
découvre qu'il y avait 50 ans que je
fais ce métier là j'ai été absolument
stupéfait c'est passé comme se penser
comme un éclair il laisse orphelins des
dizaines de personnages héros de plus de
250 album fruit de son exubérante
imagination pour la quatrième fois
seulement six réunis sur un album
quelques grands noms de la chanson
française france 2 consacre une soirée
exceptionnelle ce soir à l'événement
avec la diffusion après ce journal de
l'unique concert dont les bénéfices sont
reversés à l'association solidarité
enfants sida
cette association aide les enfants qui
souffrent du sida soit parce qu'ils en
sont atteints eux mêmes soit parce que
leurs parents sont malades
la démarche de ces chanteurs qui fasse
cette cause difficile déploient toute
leur énergie dépeinte par olivier lozat
réunion au sommet les chevaliers de la
table ronde les chevaliers de la chanson
française en croisade pour une juste
cause
vous aimez
pour la quatrième fois depuis 1990
francis cabrel michel jonasz catherine
lara maxime le forestier maurane alain
souchon et zazie se sont associés
accompagné de jean jacques goldman foden
et de beaucoup d'autres
ils ont rassemblé dans un album cette
chanson un disque inédit afin de
soutenir financièrement l'association
sol en si
indice tu es une émission en première
partie de soirée
des chansons des reportages afin de
sensibiliser le public aux besoins des
enfants et de leurs parents touchés par
le sida et vous de vivre
oui oui personnellement 92 je devais
mourir je suis toujours là
je n'aurais
jean
tu
oui
une belle leçon courage que nous sommes
ce petit garçon michel jonasz bonsoir
comment vous est venue l'idée de
soutenir justement c'est cette
association salon ci a été créée par
myriam dire s'il ya une dizaine d'années
très vite à ses côtés venu ce est venu
alain danault qui a beaucoup donné pour
se lancer qui a été le président pendant
des années qui malheureusement vient de
nous quitter il y a quelques jours on
pense bien à lui en lui dédicace cette
soirée par l'intermédiaire d'un monsieur
qui a donné beaucoup aussi pour fond
selon sir allan 4 j'ai été contacté et
l'idée était de faire connaître cette
association par des chanteurs et voilà
j'ai appelé tous mes amis de ceux que
j'aime et ce que vous allez voir ce soir
ils ont tous répondu on rit et on est
tous fidèles à se lancer depuis sa
création
ça aussi c'est un budget à peu près de
22 millions de francs par an ce donc
c'est essentiellement grâce à vous que
vie l'association je crois c'est
soixante quinze pour cent oui
où va l'argent l'argent va vraiment à
ceux qui en ont besoin
solans il peut remplir sa mission grâce
à cet argent et nous artistes nous
sommes par rapport à ça d'une grande
vigilance puisque vous savez il y aurait
des profits dans sa gloire
donc nous sommes d'une grande vigilance
et nous et d'une grande exigence des
familles d'accueil pour les ans et des
ouvertures de deux crèches et des
centres d'accueil chez des aides au
logement c'est des aides financières aux
familles défavorisées selon six aides et
soulage la douleur des enfants qui sont
touchés comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure
directement ou indirectement par le sida
par exemple et les parents qui qui sont
malades qui n'ont plus la force qui
n'ont plus le temps qu'ils n'ont plus le
courage de s'occuper des enfants ou bien
qui sont décédés aussi dont il ya une
recherche de familles d'accueil qui est
très importante
combien d'enfants à peu près qui
bénéficie beaucoup mais je crois vous
savez de cette émission de ce soir
j'espère que vous allez tous là regardez
bien salée entre couper le spectacle est
entrecoupée de deux petits reportages
qui sont très bien faits et qui
expliquent d'une façon très détaillée le
travail de seconde et puis on a vu que
il ya la sortie du disque évidemment
dont évidemment les bénéfices vont aussi
être reversés à l'association voit en ce
moment même la pochette de ce disque
donc avec un choix musical qui sont d un
peu des classiques du répertoire
français
oui on avait ans
de sortir un peu de nos habitudes et de
ne pas chanter nos propres chansons vous
savez ce que je voulais dire c'est que
c'est un vrai engagement de la part de
ces artistes là qu'est ce que c'est un
chanteur engagé aujourd'hui c'est pas
quelqu'un qui a une étiquette politique
ok créé par quelqu'un qui dit moi je
suis quelqu'un je suis un personnage
important donc ce que je vais dire ça va
avoir du poids on va m'écouter non c'est
quelqu'un qui a envie d'agir et de
participer à améliorer un peu nos
conditions de vie si on a quelque chose
à dire c'est stop
le nouveau millénaire il arrive sauf
avec les querelles de clochers et toutes
ces histoires de pouvoir politique etc
de quoi on a besoin aujourd'hui de
préserver un peu de dorloter un peu
notre planète qu'on a besoin d'un peu
plus de fraternité d'un peu plus d'amour
de deux de ne pas détourner les yeux
quand quelqu'un tend la main
voilà ce qu'on dit nous en chantant pour
se lancer d'autres pour les restos du
coeur mais c'est pas plus important
c'est pour moins importante mais ce
n'est pas plus important que le travail
du bénévole ou c'est pas plus important
que celui qui va acheter le disque
chacun peut y mettre du sien de se
lancer parce qu'il sait que c'est utile
dernière question à quand le prochain
album we see me poser la question en
mars prochain où j'aimais mes chansons
oui j'aime beaucoup moins 660 hisse donc
voulu enregistrer sa complice oui merci
michel jonasz françoise on les a appelés
les fauves parce que leurs pâtures
éclaté de couleur sauvage pour l'époque
ils ont créé un mouvement au début du
20e siècle matisse derain vlaminck
traduisent la rage de peindre de cette
génération
cet art faut celui de l'impulsion et de
la jeunesse est présentée au musée d'art
moderne de la ville de paris où 200
toiles ont été rassemblés georges bégoux
et jean-louis booth et nous font
découvrir la vitalité de cette peinture
et les lieux de prédilection de ces
peintres
en 1904 mathis pas encore ainsi en
pointillés mais déjà la couleur flamboie
en 1905 de rein fait le portrait de
matisse sans se soucier du réalisme des
couleurs la barbe et vertes et rouges le
visage jaune et vert l'influencent de 2
1 qui passe ces barques sur mathis qui
peint cette marine est flagrante
ils sont tous les deux à collioure dans
la lumière catalan inspirent ces hommes
du nord
elle supprime les ombres quand ils
peignent le phare du même endroit
leur style se confondent derain matisse
ce sont ces clubs et gardes ur lente
directement sortie du tube qui font dire
aux critiques de l'époque
ce sont des faux la main qui ne quitte
pas chatouiller bougival n'en est pas
moins conquis par le fauvisme
il fait chanter à tue-tête la lumière
vive le france pendant ce temps le
hollandais van dong m un autre fort qui
n'aiment pas la nature s'intéresse
vivement aux femmes
en 1906 c'est à l'estac prime marseille
que le fauvisme s'installe c'est le
nombril du monde
il est passé des plus grands artistes
des peintres à paulette moyennant j'ai
pas la mémoire
et oui de ramadi ce cas - manga est un
nouveau venu
georges braque qui n'est pas encore pu
beast aujourd'hui on est très étonné que
ces tableaux qui nous paraissent
extrêmement séduisant et puis à ce point
scandalisé alors il y avait en effet une
utilisation très virulent de la couleur
il y avait aussi je crois quelque chose
qui avait l'air prêt spontanéité un peu
un peu lâcher comme ça très très très
tulle cif à côté non finie aussi on
remarque ici le goût pour l'inachevé de
raoul dufy ses personnages à peine
esquissés nous sommes à sainte-adresse
tout près du havre patrick duffy avec
son ami albert marquet et il s'installe
elle assure la grève pour peindre
l'estacade les promeneurs les baigneurs
qui fréquentaient les bains de
sainte-adresse le fauvisme sera passé
comme une boule de feu au début du
siècle et seul peut être matisse or à
perpétuer la flamme tout au long de son
oeuvre
et maintenant réglons nos montres cette
nuit la plupart des pays européens passe
à l'heure d'hiver
nous allons donc gagner une heure de
sommeil supplémentaires à 3 heures cette
nuit il sera 2h
c'est à dire qu'il faudra reculer votre
réveil ou votre montre d'une heure en
souhaitant évidemment que les enfants
suivent la consigne si vous aimez faire
la grasse matinée sous être votre cas
aussi ont beau se dire que moi je passe
la nuit souvent un travail et donc voilà
mais c'est bien on gagne une heure c'est
pas moi c'est ça qu'il faut retenir une
heure de sommeil en plus ainsi se
termine ce journal je vous en rappelle
les principaux titres
les britanniques espèrent une levée
rapide de l'embargo français sur leur
viande de boeuf
en attendant les autorités affichent un
triomphe modeste le tunnel du mont-blanc
symboliquement muré cet après midi par
les habitants de la vallée de chamonix
qui manifestent contre la réouverture
prévue à l'automne 2000 dans un instant
la météo isabelle martinez 20h55 selon
si surtout ne manquez pas ce rendez vous
exceptionnel le dernier journal à 1h20
avec lens du para demain à midi paul
amar
je vous retrouve demain à 13h et
n'oubliez pas réglo montre bonsoir